der wahlkampf in den usa geht in die
heiße phase und es macht mich ja schon
stück weit stolz dass ausgerechnet die
heute show als erste wichtige deutsche
nachrichtensendung dazu eine offizielle
prognose abgibt achtung spoiler alarm
trump gewinnt die wahl ja ich weiß es
ist niederschmetternd aber ich will sie
auch nicht anlügen
dafür kennen wir uns zu lange weder die
wahl im november noch weil sie nicht
armee oder polizei kriegen den typen
jemals aus dem oval office raus ja weil
alle skandale seinen fans komplett egal
sind komplett weil er nicht mal davor
zurückschreckt corona impfung schon in
drei vier wochen zu versprechen
wahrscheinlich kommt der impfstoff ganz
zufällig am montag vor der wahl ja nun
auch schon wie das produkt heißt ja
einfach mal spritzen die wanne was soll
schon passieren
trump verhöhnt seiner eigenen solchen
experten und die wissenschaft insgesamt
auch beim thema waldbrände in
kalifornien dort warnten demokraten vor
der gefahr durch den klimawandel trump
will davon nichts wissen
es wird anfangen kühler zu werden
schauen sie einfach zu ich wünschte die
wissenschaft würde ihn zu stimmen
nun ich glaube nicht dass die
wissenschaft weiß eben was wissen schon
wissenschaftler es wird kühler punkt
sagte auf der ganzen welt haben wir
einen massiv gestiegen das
waldbrandrisiko natürlich auch wegen
klimawandel sagt schramm
das licht am wald management die frau in
kalifornien räumen ihren wald einfach
nicht genug auf
ja spontan explodierende bäume dessen
riesenproblem
auch bei uns hier bilder aus dem harz
strammer hängt die amerikaner müssten da
von den österreichern lernen hat er
diese woche gesagt denn die pflegen ihre
wälder richtig und leben zitat trump in
waldstetten weil sie mal in wien
praktisch nur baumhäusern wahrscheinlich
ein missverständnis trump hat man
verkohltes hähnchen beim wiener wald ist
egal
er wird trotzdem gewählt ich bleibe
dabei so und 2024 übernimmt dann
natürlich sein sohn john junior
diese dynastie ist gar nicht mehr
aufzuhalten wie denn auch in einer welt
wo man sogar präsident bleibt wenn man
auf tonband mitgeschnitten zugibt eine
tödliche pandemie absichtlich
heruntergespielt zu haben
das virus verbreitet sich durch die luft
das ist heikel und macht es schwierig
und es ist dazu auch noch tödlicher als
jede anstrengende grippe ich wollte es
immer herunterspielen ich mag es noch
immer 1 herunter zu spielen denn ich
will keine panik verursachen sitzt er
dann mit einem journalisten und plaudert
seinen teuflischen plan direkt ins mikro
wieder dümmste bond bösewicht aller
zeiten ist alles auf band als wäre die
alternative zu panik gar nichts tun
zigtausende amerikaner hätten gerettet
werden können wenn seine regierung
damals gehandelt hätte warum ist denn
noch im amt und dann ruft auch noch
offen zum wahlbetrug auf und sagt ey
gebt doch einfach zwei stimmen ab liebe
tram fans einmal briefwahl einmal
wahllokal ist alles wohl seinen fans ist
alles worum es erschreckend trump hat
sich durch konsequentes lügen
tatsächlich eine eigene realität
erschaffen und in der liebt ihn sogar
angela merkel sagt james ex botschafter
in berlin
ich wünschte auch so ich wäre dabei
gewesen als donald unsere engine so
verzaubert hat wie war es denn für sie
können sie die aussage des früheren
botschafters kriminell bestätigen wonach
er wurde wonach versagen hertrampf sie
verzaubert hätte herr zaubert nach so
berichtete er
ach so ach so die kurzform für wenn der
trottel verliert machen eine polonaise
er wird aber gewinnen sorry levy mich
fest ich hätte ja theoretisch deutlich
mehr hoffnung wenn die demokraten einen
kandidaten aufgestellt hätten
der zumindest ein bisschen für frische
und aufbruch steht aber so joe biden
bestimmten netter mann 77 jahre ich
meine was ist das für ein mumien duell
wirklich wie soll der sich behaupten
gegen trumps lügen feuerwerk arbeiten
wolle die polizei auflösen landesgrenzen
abschaffen und babys im neunten monat
abtreiben lassen natürlich beiden babys
nach der geburt in ihre mutter zurück
schieben um sie dann abzutreiben tram
fans glauben alles vor allem diese
jungen leute heißt es glaube ich korrekt
ausgesprochen ist eine der
gefährlichsten verschwörungstheorien
überhaupt glühende tram fans und sie
glauben ja dass eliten angeführt vom
sogenannten clinton obama klar in
unterirdischen verliesen kinder folter
auch in deutschland halten dass
inzwischen viele menschen für plausibel
denn doch nicht nur elite gibt die
kinder entlang natürlich gibt es gibt
sogar unicef ist der transporteur für
die ganze welt die kinder und links
was machen sie dann damit klar essen was
denn sonst die essen kinder da fehlt
jetzt im grunde nur noch aggressives
marketing
sie lieben kinder aber ihr supermarkt
verkauft keine macht nichts denn der
clinton obama klaren präsentiert die
leckersten kinderprodukte hillarys
babybrei ja es ist drin was draufsteht
babys brust mit gesicht ganz frisch vom
echten kindergesicht oder der klassiker
wiener kinder schnitzel vom nicht mehr
frei laufen beginnt aus österreichischer
keller haltung für den hunger auf was
kleines zwischendurch
[Musik]
nichts absolut nichts ist mehr besteuert
genug um keinen erfolg zu haben
dass die realität eine deutschsprachige
gruppe bei telegramm hat schon über 120
tausend abonnenten reden wir darüber mit
dem renommierten verschwörungstheorie
theoretiker olaf schubert olaf die cue
grund erzählung lautete ich fass es kurz
zusammen kinder werden in tunneln unter
der erde gefangen gehalten dort von
eliten gequält damit ihre zirbeldrüse
nta demo chrome produzieren und damit
erlangen böse milliardäre dann ewige
jugend meine frage könnte da irgendwas
dran sein
na ja das klingt natürlich erstmal ein
bisschen drollig und man fragt sich wer
soll das glauben aber im endeffekt ist
es ja bei den religionen das gleiche ja
also die die frau wurde erschaffen aus
meiner rippe könnte auch von pippi
langstrumpf sein und ich denke wir sind
uns alle einig jeder weiß ist natürlich
quatsch dass man breno chrom aus kindern
herstellen also da kann man genauso gut
jungfrauen nehmen und es ist aber
richtig dass ausschließlich millionäre
das anwenden aber auch nicht alle ja
also zum beispiel carsten maschmeyer hat
wirklich nur arme rentner ausgesaugt und
ich finde aber adriano chrome muss auch
breiteren schichten der bevölkerung
zugänglich werden und ich freue mich
dass ich jetzt schnupperangebote gibt
also keinen leid da arbeitet man mit der
zirbeldrüse von hamstern und erzielt
sehr gute ergebnisse ich habe es
getestet ich habe mich wirklich um tagen
geführt und ich glaube wenn es dann also
auch breiteren schichten der bevölkerung
zugänglich wird dann wird die eu seien
seine mythische faszination verlieren
das würde dann so was wie botox und
fußpflege das wird alltag
manche sagen ja es gab bei uns immer
schon den gleichen anteil von bekloppten
nur durch das internet tun sie
sicherheit zusammen ist da was dran
ich finde wir müssen da differenzieren
ich finde es immer sehr pauschal die
bekloppten da muss man also
unterscheiden es gibt die bekloppten es
gibt die bescheuerten und die total
verstrahlten so insgesamt ist das
vielleicht ein anteil von 20 prozent
schätzt man die dunkelziffer wird immer
höher sein aber 20 prozent
na das ist jeder fünfte kann es aus
rechnen also 12345 also das sind bei
zwei leuten fast 50 prozent ja und ich
will es nicht sagen dass sie alle doof
sind sondern die haben die haben die
vernunft überwunden
ja also die haben sich von den
herkömmlichen informationsquellen
abgekapselt und die besuchten die er
selbst das ist so das ist wie so ein
schwanz der sie ins gesicht bei ist so
muss man sich das vorstellen
ja also das ist es so schwarm
intelligenz reziprok naja also ein meint
[ __ ] inter gruppe quasi an zerebraler
rudel booms so absolut man hält sich ja
selber immer für immun gegen
verschwörungstheorien oder gibt es eine
die für dich attraktiv wäre ja schon der
klassiker sag ich mal elfter september
trägt ja auch wieder mal informationen
zugespielt jetzt hat eine herausgefunden
fand ich sehr brisant der elfte
september war ja in wirklichkeit am 8
april
das leuchtet ein wenn man darüber
nachdenkt aber ich bin jetzt nicht
derjenige der sagt hier wenn es den
impfstoff gibt dann ist da so ein
mikrochip trainer und wir werden alle
gescheut das ist ja quatsch das kleine
chips gibt ja noch gar nicht
aber ich bin mir sicher wir werden schon
diese kleinen radius kriegen die gibt es
eine mini kofferradios mit so ganz keine
antennen und dann sind die drinnen dann
sagen die immer nachrichten an die ganze
zeit öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk hier
setzten sich fest im kopf lösen immer
claus kleber und damit wir sind
natürlich eine totale marionette kannst
du gar nicht machen du bist ja dann
komplett gestört und wenn es einmal so
weit ist dann haben wir im endeffekt gar
keine chance mehr über und seine brücken
und herren wir lagen gedanken
was wie viel euro und alle sobald wir
eine million abonnenten nahm liebe liebe
liebe fans ich würde mich so was schon
freuen wenn ihr ein abo damals auch hier
würde den gern etwas unglücklich machen